[Applause]
right so that's part a that was the
first question i wanted to have a look
at closely i'm going to skip this
integral because it was done pretty well
let's have a look at part c which is a
mechanics question
a particle moves in a straight line such
that x double dot our acceleration is
equal to this particular exponential
function they give us where x is the
displacement in centimeters at time t
seconds
they give you initial an initial
condition namely that the particle's at
the origin so there is a let's use this
color there's a displacement piece of
information and then they also say it's
moving with a velocity of two
centimeters per second so that's
important too determine an equation for
velocity in terms of displacement okay
so v in terms of x right let's have a go
at this so this is
part c i'm going to let's let's just
start a new page
here we go part c
now if i just start with this
equation of motion that's been handed to
me which is x double dot equals minus 2
e to the minus x knowing that i need to
head towards an equation for v in terms
of x i have two very valid choices for
how i'm going to express acceleration
that will allow me to integrate most
effectively from acceleration up into
velocity and honestly they both work
just fine so i'm going to show you both
let's have a go at let's go with method
one
let's use the
the d half v squared on dx versions so
if i just choose i don't know why my e
is so messy and that's bothering me
there we go if we just choose to define
that left hand side as d on dx
of
half v squared
that's going to be equal to minus 2 e to
the minus x what are we going to do here
well i'll double everything so i just
have v squared so that's going to give
me d on dx of v squared is equal to
negative 4 out the front e to the
negative x and i'm ready at this point
to just integrate with respect to x
which leaves me with that v squared on
the left hand side there's no reason for
us to worry about putting that constant
coefficient inside the integral and that
just leaves me with e to the negative x
dx actually i take that back
having that minus sign is kind of handy
because of course
that's going to be my inside derivative
of my inside function up there so this
is looking really good right when i do
my
integration i'm just going to get on the
right hand side the 4 is hanging out
there and then it's just going to be e
to the minus x plus a constant
like so
now
i can use the initial conditions that
i've been provided to work out what this
constant is so i can say being that i've
got
an x equals an sorry an x value here and
a v over here the initial condition it's
um
my question paper is going away here we
go our initial condition you might think
like oh where do i put t equals 0
because it's initially right but what
i've got here is independent of time all
i need to say is
at the same moment i'm at the origin
which is what's it easy there we go oh
where's my cursor gone
it's absolutely disappeared there we go
huh
funny it's playing up
yeah my curse is here
and
it's not there weird it doesn't matter
i'm just going to keep on going i'm at
the origin there we go
and as already highlighted before i have
a v equals 2 right so i can substitute
that in right here i can say
when
x equals 0 v equals 2. so therefore i
can put this in and evaluate c so what
i'm going to get is on the left hand
side 2 squared is 4.
you're going to get 4 times e to the 0
here and remembering that e to the power
of 0 is 1
i can subtract 4 from both sides and get
the fact that that constant is equal to
0.
so therefore what have i got here v
squared is equal to 4 e to the negative
x we didn't want
velocity squared as a function of x we
wanted velocity so therefore i'm going
to take the square root of both sides
that leaves me with careful here plus or
minus i'm taking the square root of
4 which gives me the 2
and then i just using index laws i'll
have e to the negative x on 2 here okay
now at this point here i'm going to need
to deal with the fact that i've got a
plus or minus because like which one is
it which one has to be the function
velocity is it the plus or is it the
minus what information do i have access
to now again if you just go back to the
fact that
v equals 2 when x equals 0
that's a positive velocity right so
therefore if i put in x equals 0 back
into here you can see if the negative
case were true i'd get v equals negative
2 times e to the 0 that's negative 2.
but i already know that's not the case
right so i need to appeal to that again
i can say but
v is positive when
x equals 0. so therefore that allows me
to exclude the negative case so i can
say therefore v is equal to 2 e to the
negative x on 2. and it was no dice if
you just kind of you know left out this
statement here and just chose the
positive one because if you didn't have
a reason for it it was arbitrary it
didn't show understanding that you knew
why to eliminate the negative option
okay so there's your velocity function
as requested now i promised earlier that
i would show what it would look like if
you didn't use this method i didn't
mention it earlier but you can think
about the fact that there's one other
form for acceleration that makes it easy
to get velocity as a function of x and
that is of course v dv on dx so let's
use that instead and see what happens if
you go v dv on dx and let that equal to
minus 2 e to the minus x
what's going to happen well
you can see here
if i integrate both sides i don't know
why that x is so messy if i integrate
both sides with respect to x what do we
get well i'm going to have my integral
of v dv over on the left and then i'm
going to have
i'll do the same thing that i did before
pull out that 2 but i'll leave the minus
sign in here to go with that negative x
dx so you can see what i've done i'm
getting that
let's put it in blue this v dv up here
has remained on the left hand side
and this
dx over here is what has sort of
combined with the e to the negative x on
the right hand side to give me a
reasonable integral okay
now
at this point to make it easier for me
there's an additional thing that i can
do like i've already shown you you can
evaluate the constant and so on but
because i you know i've
recognized the fact that i'm going to
need to use the initial condition over
here to evaluate that constant i can
actually do this in this line when i
introduce the integral right what i can
do is i can say let's consider the that
initial condition and then some
arbitrary velocity and displacement
right so when i'm initially when i'm at
t equals zero where am i and the answer
is i am at the origin x equals zero so
that goes with the x boundaries over
here on the right hand side
by the same token initially what
velocity do i have and the answer is v
was given as 2 right so you can see how
these correspond to each other and then
i can just say well let's just compare
some other arbitrary x and arbitrary v
that pair up and this will be enough
because they're now both definite
integrals
to not have to worry about the constant
at all right so i just need to evaluate
these let's have a go
i'm going to get v squared onto
from 2 to v
and then over here i've got
2 outside of e to the negative x from 0
to x
so far so good definite integrals let's
do our evaluation
substituting v into v i know that's a
sneaky thing but you just get v squared
on 2 when you put 2 in our lower
boundary you're going to get
2 squared on 2 so that goes in the v
let's deal with that in a second after
doing the right hand side i've got the 2
there
substituting x into x you're going to
get e to the negative x and then i'm
subtracting 2 because that that 2 right
there multiplies by everything on the
inside that's e to the 0 which of course
i know is 1.
so what am i getting here um i am going
to multiply everything through by two to
get that uh v squared on its uh sort of
you know make easier to make the subject
so i'll get v squared minus four is
equal to what i've got on the right hand
side so multiply by two that gives me
four e to the minus x which i hope looks
familiar
minus 4 because that was just going to
be 2 and i just doubled it
and then i'm adding 4 to both sides that
gives me v squared equals 4 e to the
negative x and at this point where am i
i'm right here
so everything else just kind of carries
on as uh before so whether you used d on
dx half v squared or v dv on dx they
both landed you there
though you do you do see if you can
handle this sort of definite integral
sort of somersault this um sort of
calculus trick i think the working does
end up a little bit straight more you
know sort of efficient because you're
not having to do a secondary working of
the constant even though that's very
easy